nous aurons cette semaine aux
territoires du nord ouest où les
citoyens doivent se rendre aux urnes
demain pour élire un nouveau
gouvernement changera au pays il
n'existe pas de parti politique dans ce
territoire
tous les candidats sans exception sont
indépendants sylvain basse car on nous
explique pourquoi un gouvernement par
consensus donc aux territoires du
nord-ouest où comme au nunavut ce sont
les deux seuls territoires au canada qui
fonctionne de cette façon alors les
candidats ne représente aucun parti il
n'y a pas de partie dans ce système mais
quand ils seront élus ils voteront en
secret pour un président d'assemblée un
premier ministre six ministres restera
ensuite 11 simple député et puis pour
chaque enjeu tout le monde aura le droit
de s'exprimer
l'objectif est d'en arriver à un
consensus à l'image des premières
nations de l'anci et ans qui discutait
pendant des jours et des jours et des
jours pour se diviser le territoire de
chasse c'est une belle idée ce n'est pas
un système qui est parfait nous a
expliqué le professeur de l'université
laval en sciences politiques thierry
redon il nous a expliqué que c'est
notamment très difficile d'avoir une
vision globale parce que chaque député
représente seulement sa circonscription
et qu'il n'y a pas de chef de parti
c'est toujours la question de l'intérêt
général par rapport à l'intérêt
particulier là quand on représente une
circonscription bleus il y en a plus de
mal à définir l'intérêt général qui est
l'intérêt de l'ensemble du territoire
donc un système qui n'est pas parfait il
ya place à l'amélioration par contre un
chef financier chef autochtone et
premier ministre du territoire à qui
nous avons parlé nous a expliqué que les
politiciens se dorait tout avantage à
s'inspirer de cette l'idée de la
recherche du consensus qui est de
tradition autochtone
il lance donc le défi à justin trudeau
de parler aux membres de tous les partis
avant de prendre ses décisions